James: Hi YouTube, I'm Jim Schiro, the CEO
of Zurich Financial Services.
And as they know, I'm in Davos, there's a
lot of dialogue going around regarding the
current economic crisis.
The responsibility that people must take for
that crisis.
And yes I think as part of the financial services
community, we have to say we didn't deliver
on our promises and we failed to deliver on
those promises.
I had the opportunity to participate in a
panel discussing the importance of values.
I think values are important; executives should
be accountable to living up to those values.
I'm not sure that the publication of a series
of ethics policies -- I think most companies
have a policy that says these are the ethics
we expect for executives.
I think the important thing is we have to
hold executives accountable for living those
ethics more and those policies.
I think that's really the foundation of the
values that excellent companies do have.
So I'm optimistic as we go through this process
that we will see a greater light shine on
those people who are truly living the values
of their organization.